人狼は満月を見ると狼になります。
あ、誰かをした。
くし
うじ大丈夫か?
宇じだめだ。もう死んでる。
おならをしたのは一体誰だ?
ゆと君あなたでしょ?な、
なんで僕なんよ。
授業中横でボリボリ芋ケたの知ってるんだからね。
ここ5
回なんよ。芋ケは食べたけどお腹はしてないよ。それにこれはこんな
こいつが犯人よ。
そうだ。言い訳やめろ。へこきやろ。
お前が追報だ。
[拍手]
よし、行け。ちゃ、
キ大丈夫か?
僕の群馬で犯人を見つけたせ、
[音楽]
だめだ。死んでいる。
間違いない。この中に嘘つきがいる。
そして見つけ出さないと全滅する。
こ、こんなのまるね。
俺の人狼じゃねえか。
こんじり。お前優と早々に犯人扱いしたな。なんか怪しかったぞ。
だって芋ケを食べてたのを知ってたんだから疑うのは当然でしょ。
落ち着け。確かにゆが食べてたのは事実だ。だけど
1個引っかかるんだよな。え?何?
ゆうとがあんな大量の芋をどうやって用意したのか。
確かにな。あいつ美なのにどうやってぼけんだよ。先生。先生が最近芋にはまってるのはもう分かってるんだ。行く。
[音楽]
髪にもほら芋皮ついてますよ。これは違う。おそらくゆとは先生の机から芋を盗んだ。だがほとんどはすでに食べられていた。ま先生が食べたってことですよね。違う。俺じゃない。
おじさんの変なら殺傷称傷能力が高いのことが行く。犯人はお前だ。
待って屋根君。なんでそれに気づいててゆト君が処刑される時止めなかったの?
だってしこれはきさせるは仕方なかったんだよ。
それにおなの音がした時1
人だけ立ち上がるのが早かったよね。まるで椅子を引きずる音でごまかすかのように。
お俺じゃない。俺はおなんて。
そうさ、俺がおならをしたのさ。なかなかやるな、こじり。君の推理は正しいだが。勝つのはこの俺だ。
整理しよう。今疑いがあるのは先生と俺だ。でも確実な消化を疑いに揃ってない。ここは平等投票で決めよう。
[音楽]
この連静さ、どういうこと?屋根君ではないの?それに比べて
どうもアレリへこのメに歌ってくれ。処刑の初刑
先生はこの必死やっぱりこっちが苦労
これ以上証拠が出てこないなら今はこんじりを味方につけないとそのためなら俺は
こんじり君にこれ以上怖い思いをして欲しくないんだ。あのじじを処刑して
2人で幸せになろう。うん。そうだね。
俺は狼にだってなれる。
おお。
それじゃあせので指刺そう。
えへ
せーの。
え、先生1票。根助君2
票で屋根助君に決定。
はな、なんでこんち
[音楽]
ゃあなたに握られたその手で確信したの。
ほのかにでも確実に感じた握りをした手よ。
くそしてよ。ふざけた。
おしまいです。
バイバイ。
よし、ケタ。
イエーイイエーイ
[音楽]
ピー。
臭すぎる。
狼が1匹なんて誰が決めたのあ